when you consider even the cost of going
to coding boot camp not only the
financial cost but the toll it has on
your mental
health mental stability your own self
and the people around you that's a big
cost so let's make sure we are doing
everything we can to make sure all of
the tip top shape to go hello everybody
my name is zion i'm the black female
engineer i provide content for new and
inspiring software engineers and today
we are talking about how to make it
through coding bootcamp let this serve
you as your coding bootcamp survival
guide of 2022. and i know where haven't
passed the january threshold just yet
but it is november which means it's
thanksgiving which means it's christmas
which means it's new years which means
it's february so let's get right in so
if you haven't watched my coding
bootcamp survival guide of about a
year-ish nine months ago i highly
recommend you check that out after this
i'm trying not to repeat myself and
really provide new insights uh with a
whole new mindset whole new perspective
and so when talking how to make it
through all like all this that you're in
right now we need to look at okay where
are
students to meet students because you're
learning something so where are students
most likely
to kind of drop off so i went to coding
bootcamp june of
june of 2020 to october of 2020 and
through my experience there i
saw three main places and so one i would
say students have the largest risk of
yeah not making it through after coding
challenges so coding challenges was
something my specific bootcamp had and i
imagine many do because they're
basically ways to test how much you've
learned and retained uh over these last
x amount of weeks i went to flat art
school and for me this happened every
three weeks and so every three weeks you
had this like week where you were just
trying to make it through and solve the
coding challenge it was basically kind
of a mix between a mini project and an
exam kind of a mix between the two more
mini project than exam but the mindset
is kind of like yeah it's a test and so
coloring challenges really being yeah
the biggest risk then the second being
projects and project weeks those were
also every three weeks they were the
week after coding challenges and so if
your project was not up to par with the
standards that they have set then you
could also be left behind and then
finally just the regular day-to-day
learning and the student dropping off
because they can't keep up with either
the material or they can't retain that
information um as fast as other people
and whatnot because bootcamp
is quick and so if you can't you know go
quickly it's very hard to catch back up
so how do we address these things how do
we survive these things so we'll start
with the
coding challenges section let me say
this advice is specifically based off my
experience at flat iron and with coding
challenges we didn't just have one test
and then if you pass you pass and then
boom or and if you failed you were
kicked out you had about four tries to
pass and so you do it on monday if you
fail then you do it tuesday you fail to
do it wednesday you fail you do it
thursday and if you fail thursday that
sounds good okay uh goodbye now the
reason that's important is because my
number one tip for
getting passed for surviving coding
challenges is to treat that first try
not as a coding challenge at all treat
that first try as a mechanism for just
showing you which topics you may need to
be better acquainted with and more
comfortable with if you employ that
mentality
in your first attempt at coding
challenges then coding challenges are a
lot less stressful because here is what
i recommend walk up in there right
we're virtual but
walk up in there into you know onto your
desk pull up the coding challenge and
just read it read it all the way through
understand what is being asked of you
take notes as to okay what specifically
is being asked that i do what specific
topics is it honing in on is it honing
in on iterative statements is it honing
in on understanding um json or the use
of dictionaries or objects um depending
on the language you're using and so what
is it really honing in on what topic is
this specifically relating to take all
those notes and then try your best to
just see where you can go with it
again have the mindset of my goal isn't
to pass my goal is to see
where maybe my blind spots are and so
try to see how far you can go and the
second you hit a roadblock note it note
it down try to figure out why exactly
you hit that roadblock is it because you
don't know where to go next after doing
a specific step is it because you don't
know why you do the specific step note
all of those things and just keep on
going and if you can't surpass that
roadblock then go back to reading the
code challenge what is ask review and
everything and try to make a mental note
like okay this even if i did get past
this roblox i think i would have issues
with this and then this this is this and
then boom we always had about three
hours to complete the code challenge two
to two to four maybe three and a half
maybe three and a half but then boom
your time is up it goes way faster than
you think and your time is up and then
now you can spend the rest of your day
addressing those problem areas you had
now you know exactly what you are
struggling with you know exactly what
your where your blinders are where you
stumble and so spend the rest of the day
going through that line by line practice
like crazy build and burn and build if
you don't know what i mean by bildenberg
go back to that first coding bootcamp
survival guide but yes build and burn
and build and burn and continue that
over and over until you just can't get
it wrong do that for the entire
day seriously do it for the entire day
and then boom your second try i bet you
you'll go a lot further than you did
your first and then boom you finished it
in two tries then if you need to go to
the third or fourth even if you do go to
the third or fourth make sure in the
previous attempts you're doing this
exact same thing make sure you're noting
exactly where you are getting stuck what
roblox you're on and once the coding
challenge stops reach out to people
reach out to instructors reach out to
peers go to the additional resources
provided by your boot camp and ask you
don't have to say how do i solve problem
three of the coding challenge because
i'm pretty sure that's not a lot but you
can just say hey how do i map through
objects in javascript then that's
like a legit uh topic and a legit skill
that you need enhancing and so then of
course like okay yeah let's schedule a
zoom call let's do some pair programming
um let's do like another session of
teaching and everything and we can go
through this i know it can be hard to
reach out to people but you gotta gotta
got it because on the job you'll be
reaching out to people the amount of
people i've reached out to in the last
like 24 hours is absurd so all around
you're learning on to number two the
second
area the second part the second
reason people can drop off is because
they did not meet requirements for or
expectations for their projects this
again happened about every three weeks
and so when you get to that project
section
make sure that before you start your
project you reach out to your
instructors through your teachers and
say hey this is my idea these are the
features it would have
like the way i would code it out would
it meet your standards for passing
boom
a lot of times i have seen a lot of
things can be simplified and avoided
simply by having asked a question
just one question and so no reach out to
your instructors like y'all nobody here
wants you to fail at all
at all and so
when you consider even the cost of going
to coding boot camp not only the
financial cost but the toll it has on
your mental
health mental stability your own self
and the people around you that's a big
cost so let's make sure we are doing
everything we can to make sure all is
good top tip top shape to go and one of
those is asking questions and asking the
right questions and that is a question i
want y'all to ask every single time it's
time to develop a project and then boom
you know exactly what to do to pass
through that project second tip i have
for you all in surviving projects week
is making sure you have your mvp down
now what's an mvp and mvp stands for
minimally viable product and so what is
the least amount of things
i need to put in this project in order
to pass in order for the app to be
functioning and in order for it to pass
here is like an example i remember my
instructor shared this example actually
i'm going to butcher it so don't quote
me but basically it was the idea of
instacart instacart is a grocery
delivery app and whatnot and i guess in
the very beginning stages it really was
just kind of more text messaging of okay
you send this like large text to a
community of shoppers and say all the
things you need and which store you want
and then they would do that and deliver
to your home not this whole huge
interface of like okay i want
strawberries and then quantity two and
then going to shopping cart and putting
my credit card like all these you know
features and these bells and whistles
everywhere that we see now but in
essence that's what it was in the very
beginning stage and it worked
and that's what an mvp is so think about
what the mvp for your app is and make
that your goal of just okay for these
next x amount of days i'm just going to
focus on the mvp and then once you get
past the mvp
then focus on making it this bells and
whistles thing and making the user
interface gorgeous and having these you
know sound effects and everything that's
where you can focus on that because
if you have sound effects that's great
but if the app doesn't load that's an
issue and so make sure you're not
wasting your time because again what
we're trying to do is simply this this
whole video is simply getting you to
that finish line and so to get to that
finish line all you need is the minimum
the minimum so figure out what that
minimum is and again this could be
something that you actually reach out to
your um instructions about and ask okay
this is what i think is a minimally
viable product what do you think and
there are times when i
had those meetings with instructors and
they'd be like oh actually
that's not even minimally viable if you
take out these two features then it's
actually minimally viable so make sure
you focus on this bare minimum first and
then start adding on those features
because what i don't want to see is you
all get the go-ahead for a specific app
and that that's enough for you to pass
but then because you're focusing on all
these bells and whistles you never
actually finished the project and now
you don't pass that stage in a bonus tip
make sure you're also not wasting time
by thinking about creating the most
lavish
big grand app
like
it's not that deep um you don't need to
make the new stock market app the new
robin hood the new like airplane monitor
or whatever you don't need to do any of
that think of like
you can i don't think don't i'm not
saying don't like definitely do like
what your heart desires but what i'm
saying is don't stress yourself out
thinking you have to have this most
lavish app instead think of just like a
basic thing like let's say a to-do list
and figure out the mvp and then if you
have time then start thinking about what
features you can add onto the to-do list
that would make it this you know more
lavish thing and so let's say
after
you uh
complete one item off the list then it
tracks how many like let's say cookie
points you have and by the time you have
five clicking points then you can treat
yourself in some way for accomplishing
things on your to-do list just like for
example yeah a feature you could add and
so now it's becoming from it's it's
going from this one's basic thing which
which you know basically i don't know
please get degrees i'm just saying but
yes if you do have the time then you can
start thinking about those bells and
whistles on to make it more impressive
so think less about what app you can
create that would be impressive and
think more what features can i add to
the super basic app that would make it
um like maybe different or you know
impressive and whatnot if if you have
the time and then finally the last you
know the third spot where trouble can
occur is and the simple learning and
just feeling like you can't retain or
like feeling that you are not retaining
the information or at least not as
quickly as you need to to keep up pace
some things to do on that one
pair program seriously
i'm depending on the boot camp you're in
or the campus you're in it may feel like
you're in this like hunger games world
where you can't show any weakness and
you can't make like let up and have to
always look like you have everything
down like that's not gonna go too well
for you i'll tell you that right now and
so instead book times and sessions where
you can pair program with other people
make it recurring where it's like okay
once a week we as a group get together
and repair program or every other day at
this specific hour me and this person
pair program and we switch places and
whatnot if you don't know really how to
repair program or how to pair program
effectively check out this video above i
do a whole you know rundown on all of it
but yes prayer program it can be such an
amazing way to learn but also not only
just learn but learn quickly because now
you have two brains uh working and that
can be a fantastic
and magical thing and so one pair
program and two just like the coding
challenge keep track of what things
you're struggling on so that at the end
of the day you can go specifically to
those things that you're not wasting
your time on subjects
and
processes and
all these things that you're actually
good on it can be that's something i
struggle with is when i'm struggling
with something instead of like studying
the thing i'm struggling with i'm like
doing the things i'm good at which gets
me nowhere and so when you write down
like during the class like okay so when
once the instructor started talking
about x y and z i really just couldn't
follow along when you write that down
you know exactly what you need to tackle
on your own or reaching out to the
instructor or reaching out to your um
classmates your cohort mates and saying
okay it's like let's figure this out
because yeah i really have a couple
weeks and then you know i find out if i
get the boot or not and so make sure
you're keeping track of that so
definitely keep some type of developer
journal and record your everyday
experiences every day because like i
said in a day the amount of things you
learn is equivalent to
weeks and weeks and weeks if you're
doing it on your own or even in college
so make sure you're keeping track of
those things and so there we go
everybody my coding bookkeep survival
died of
2022. and so again make sure you check
out the previous coding bootcamp
survival guide because i try my best not
to repeat myself and so there are some
very very very good
good tips in there that um i think will
help you out a lot as well but please
also don't forget to subscribe please
don't forget to like i really appreciate
the support it helps me out helps my
channel a ton and you liking and
subscribing helps my videos reach more
people who also would like assistance
and help and are also trying to do this
amazing thing of switching careers in a
very short amount of time and so please
help me and help them as well so thank
you so so so much and yeah i will talk
to you all later bye y'all